okay cool well so it's been I don't know
how many of you people are old-timers
who actually know who I am but it's been
quite a while since I've even been to
one of these conferences because as it
happens I was always in London whatever
they were happening or whatever but so I
for those we don't know was the original
author of the mathematica notebook front
end many many many years ago but have
not actually done much here for a while
and so I'm going to start off which is
it'll be like a three-part talk i'm
going to start off by giving you a very
brief update of some of the things I've
been what's my name you say people don't
know who I am it's out it's right there
on the schedule anyway my name is
Theodore grey in fact you can tell that
from my url so these are a few of the
things that I've been off doing working
on on element books and new molecule
book which is just come out and various
other sorts of things in particular
starting a company called touch press
which grew out of the elements app and
relevant to you know mathematic and why
I'm here is that in many cases even
though we're developing ipad apps at
least for the ones where I'm involved in
detail in the design and production of
them I make very heavy use of
Mathematica in various perhaps
unexpected ways to to you know to
develop these apps so I'll tell you just
a few examples of how that works two of
them from the app disney animated so
this was an app that i ended up being
the author oven and kind of designer of
even though when i was growing up i was
not actually allowed to watch disney
movies because my family considered them
lowbrow or something so i had to do sort
of a crash course in how great disney is
which actually it turns out it is
actually pretty amazing what some of the
things that they did and so we were we
were engaged in this project to make an
appt all about disney and one of the
things in it was a simulation what I
call an authentic replica because Disney
likes that kind of
knology of the snow in the movie frozen
which has just come out last year and so
the snow that's in that movie is of
course CGI snow and it's a tremendously
complicated algorithm runs you know
minutes per frame or something on big
super computers but we need to make
something would run in real time on an
iPad and this is this is an example of
our you know our code running on an iPad
and you can just swipe your finger and
you get it and it works and the way this
was done basically was me sitting with a
laptop running Mathematica in a room
full of the Disney effects engineers
tweaking the algorithm in Mathematica
sort of in real time making it trainer
trying to get it to look like they're
very complicated fluid dynamics thing
that they have and it was really
fundamental to the ability to do that
that the whole thing in Mathematica was
a couple dozen lines long maybe most of
which was kind of fluff and the heart of
it is very simple and because of that it
was possible to sort of completely
recast the algorithm a couple of times
and of course you know it was doing with
maybe 500 particles running in a dynamic
module which was actually something I
invented many years ago and it was kind
of satisfying to see that actually does
work when you get on the other side of
the fence it really does work as
advertised and it's very useful thing
and we eventually came up with something
where we did with 500 particles and sort
of qualitatively looked right and then
we re implemented the whole thing in C
code and OpenGL to run in real time on
an iPad another thing that we did was I
had this idea that we should have some
way of showing an entire movie
representing it in one single image in a
way that would sort of capture some
essence of the movie and make it
recognizable at least to somebody who
knows the movie as being characteristic
of that film and here's the code that it
sort of turns out to be key to that the
issue is that what I wanted to show sort
of the progression of colors throughout
the movie because movies kind of they
have a rhythm to them and they there's
kind of ups and downs and there's happy
scenes and sad scenes and this is often
very carefully engineered in terms of
the color palette and I wanted to sort
of pull out
and people have tried to do this people
make like little micro thumbnails you
know poster with a whole movies all the
thumbnails but the problem with that is
that as soon as you sort of pull back
the point where you're seeing the whole
movie everything has gotten so small
that all the colors blend together in
exactly the way that pixels on a screen
blend together so like if you have a
frame that's a red car in a green field
with blue sky you know very bright
primary colors you shrink it down and
it's just brown or gray or something
there's no color left because everything
blends so what you have to do if you
want to preserve the colors is you have
to sort of pull them apart and you have
to essentially sort them but you can't
sort them because colors are
three-dimensional things and there's no
sorting order that will get you anything
sensible you know you can't sort by
brightness pics in the hues are
scattered you can't sort by Hugh because
then the brightnesses are scattered what
you have to do is cluster them and so it
turns out this little bit of code was
the key to making this possible you just
you import frames of the movie you take
the data as if that was just XYZ data
and you simply call find clusters on it
I didn't have to use the options and it
very effectively identifies typically
half a dozen or so groupings of color
that are more similar to each other
particularly with animated movies and
then I use that as the sort of first
order sort to pull the colors apart and
this is what the output of that code
with a few little extra things options
and things looks like so you can see
this is a frame from Lion King and there
are you know there's some blurriness
whatever some fuzzing but there's
clearly some blue some green you know
some dark some Browns whatever and this
is a little movie that i made also of
course a hundred percent using
Mathematica that illustrates this
process you break it up you do a cluster
you sort the clusters by brightness then
by brightness within and they do that
for every frame and you just kind of
keep doing that and eventually you get
an image that's the entire movie this is
a close-up here and you see there's
there's no blending there's never any
averaging of colors there's only
selection obviously you have to cut it
down selection and pulling apart and
sorting
and here's this is all of Lion King and
if you know Lion King you can actually
you can basically trace the plot out you
know there's there's fire at the ends
kind of cut off there you know there's
happy they're sad there's whoever they
are timba and the other guy you know off
i don't know i'm not i'm not actually a
disney expert so these this each one of
these images takes about 24 hours of
time on an eight cormac tower to do you
know extract the frames for the movie
extract the pixels put them into groups
kind of those cuts where the camera
shifts takes pools of pixels clusters
them and generates this final output
image and you'll see one of these in in
the app for every movie it's direct
output of mathematica there's no
post-processing or whatever you'll also
see this which is my favorite image of
that I produced in recent times this is
every single Disney movie from Snow
White through frozen and I don't know
how well it's coming through on the
projector but it's really kind of cool
you can see trends in the color palettes
that are used even though in this screen
you're seeing 75 years of moviemaking as
I did the math there's on a 5 megapixel
retina iPad screen every pixel in the
image represents about an eight-hour
workday to produce it because of course
in order to make this image you first
have to make all the movies and it takes
hundreds of men years of work per movie
so there's just a an astonishing amount
of human effort that's been crunched
down and compressed and put into one
image and it's remarkable you can do
that and actually still see anything and
and you know and mathematical is
absolutely fundamental nobody has ever
tried to do this before because nobody
has applied you know sort of level of
mathematical analysis to it that's
necessary and there we go exactly ten
minutes as allocated to the introductory
portion of the talk because now we're
going to move on to something completely
different which is a different thing
that I've been doing together with my
lovely collaborator and
amazingly also girlfriend Nina will be
doing this talk with me and that is
something called stitch coding which is
a word that it made up because I was
feeling too nerdy and I thought there
should be a better word for this this
particular process our application of
mathematica which you know is another
kind of thing that doesn't it doesn't
sound like it's very mathematical like
you know making images and movies maybe
not so mathematical likewise quilting
and embroidery maybe don't initially
sound like they're difficult
mathematical problems but it turns out
if you want to do them in a certain way
they're actually tremendously complex
mathematical challenges for which the
world needs Mathematica so we're going
to talk a bit so so so this is two
fundamental domains quilting an
embroidery they're they're actually
quite different even though they both
involve thread the number one thing
about quilting is the thread must go on
don't cut the thread because any time
you do that there's trouble so when you
look at quilt designs like this pretty
much everything is one continuous line
it's been you know all stitched without
stopping at least that's the first
approximation sometimes you have to and
so then you deal with it I've been
rather than looking at a design that
complicated first let's look at this
this so this is what I initially would
have considered a pretty simple design
it turns out for commercial stitch you
know quilting and embroidery software
this is way beyond the level of
complexity that they are able to handle
finding a route to to stitch this with
if you give them anything more than
about the head it just it just crashes
or just can't do it it says nevermind
can't do that the challenge here is you
know you have this design you want to
stitch it without stopping so it turns
out using trivially recast into a
network traversal problem every place
that a line meets another line like at a
t-intersection that's a node and all the
connections between those nodes are
edges of the graph and so here's that
same figure it's the same lion thing
except we've just let you know graph
plot layout the connectivity of it
so that we can examine it as a graph
problem and then you you call this
beautiful function find posts mentor and
you're done it takes less than a minute
to do you know you call that function
and it's simply done and this is the
path that it finds it you know it's it's
a theorem that for anything beyond the
simplest graphs you will have to double
stitch some lines and that's okay the
machines pretty accurate but you know
boom there you go and here's the video
of an embroidery machine you know once
you've got the path which just the file
format is incredibly trivially just a
purchased a set of XY coordinates that
they switch gears this research here and
the Machine does it now you may wonder
oh you're going to hold right up in a
minute but not yet because you're having
nothing you may wonder why you know I
mean people you can do this by hand
people people have done this many times
and that this is a slightly fancier
version without the noise people have
made designs like this of course people
have done you know much much more
elaborate automated embroidery designs
like this but they do them by hand which
is a pain and they're particularly pain
if you want to do it more than once and
as it happens Nina is an animator and so
we never do anything once so here's the
same code run multiple times on multiple
patterns that are all subtly different
and I'll have completely different
connectivity the graph from one is
unrelated to the graph for the next one
and so here it is stitched out with some
embellishments and there's some echoing
and things
and the wonderful thing about doing
something physical like this is you
don't end up with justice thing you can
show on the screen you get like a thing
can we pass it around or something else
it's it's like it's soft and warm just
throw it out there something it's not
just an algorithm it's an algorithm that
becomes anyway so now now let's look at
a much more complicated design so this
is a thousand dollar bill this is a this
is a scan you know of a nineteen thirty
four thousand dollar bill this is Nina's
expert lineart rendering of it so in
this image there are no Phil's there's
no polygons whatever there's just lines
we can see that we look at a close-up of
it it's just a whole bunch of the lines
and no no we're not ready to die yet
they only part of this that I can take
responsibility for are these what are
called DHA patterns a sort of security
printing patterns which I didn't know
what we're getting into this those are
actually they really are security at
least used to be before digital printing
because they're made with these sort of
it's like a spirograph with maybe ten
concentric gears and each gear is set to
a certain ratio in a certain you know
offset or whatever and it's called a
gear chalets and the thing runs and it
traces out a pattern and it's actually
it's sort of cryptographically difficult
to work backwards from the pattern to
what the settings of the wheels must
have been so if the only thing you have
is the pattern that's produced and you
wish to make an engraving plate by
tracing a stylus over a piece of metal
it's virtually impossible to do and
that's no longer the case because
printing presses now you know you can
have digital printing whatever you can
reproduce at extremely high resolution
you can't do that with thread so these
these stitch stitch dia patterns are you
know I think our cryptographically
secured identify this particular design
and you know we're not releasing that
the parameters to make that anyway so
again it's a it's a you know we need to
stitch it has to be one line but there's
way more lines in this one and here's
these are just a selection terms that
you can't actually do it as one because
there's separate letters there's various
parts of it have to be disconnected so
breaks down into a couple of
as in separate graphs and these are
images of those graphs this is the main
one there's one big chunk which has all
the BSA patterns and all the sort of
connected stuff around it it doesn't
look that bad but but so this is like a
tiny corner of it it's a tremendously
detailed complicated graph let's see so
the statistics 50,000 nodes 64,000
connections and it turns into about
350,000 stitches once it's been
connected and it takes like four or five
hours for Mathematica to do the analysis
of the connectivity create the graph and
then do the fine postman tour call on
that to find to find a path but it finds
a path it just it keeps working and it
doesn't run out of memory and it finds a
path so in order to deal with big
patterns like this you need a big
machine this is Nina's amazing quilt
monster or something it's a fully
automated it's basically an XY plotter
except instead of a pen there's a sewing
machine and this is the engine in this
machine it's the head that moves but we
mounted a GoPro camera to the head so it
looks like the fabric moving it will go
up to 2,000 stitches per minute which is
very fast but it also will do you know
very intricate detailed little pattern
about the dawn a little tour of the
whole design
I think it does a little building around
here but then then we're going to pull
back and see the bill is working on I
guess well that's big thing we can hold
up but you can hook that one that's but
that's that's a single thousand-dollar
bill know with that what that machine is
actually working on is is this thing
which is $10,000 quilt and this has I
think it's almost two million stitches
in and roughly took about a week of
running up in the chain
and then and then just for good measure
Nina binds them all which is like
applying the ribbon around the outside
using a foot pedal treadle machine to
provide some contrast with the giant
computerized thing there's the quilt so
my little take on this is that if you
have quilted money you need to have a
bank and fortunately my other office is
located in a bank so we actually have
this is not actually our ball we have
like in the basement we have but not
less attractive vault but we do actually
have a vault and these builds are stored
in the vault and we operate a bank quilt
bank calm where you can you can exchange
these there's of course there's no
discount on money so these quilts cost a
thousand dollars and Nina has produced a
lovely checklist of the advantages of
soft money over regular you can use it
for political contributions if it gets
dirty you can launder it you know
there's all kinds of things you can do
so okay that's quilting next is
embroidery so it took as quilting is
basically fine postman tour that is the
fundamental problem of quilting the
fundamental problem of embroidery is
space-filling curves that was just a
picture of the embroidery machine there
so with embroidery you want to fill up a
whole area and this turns out also to be
quite tricky and it turns out that the
commercially available software for
doing it is also quite inadequate so
here this is a little animation that
shows this is a little test figure that
I made the idea is you want to you want
to fill up this whole shape and you
don't want to cut the thread you don't
want to start and stop so what you can
do is you can travel out to the end of a
little pocket and then stitch back and
it's fine to stitch over something you
know and then you don't see what was
underneath and so this is showing you
know turns again into a graph theory
problem you take the space and you kind
of analyze the topology of it and you
figure out what the connectivity is of
the different regions and that depends
on what direction the stitches are going
because it with the stitch is going in a
different direction it's basically what
i think of it is you have a branched
hallway and your painting you want to
paint the hallway in such a way that you
don't have to step over what you've
already painted and your OCD and you are
only willing to paint in exactly one
direction and so that determines you
know how what you can get to and
turns out you can always do it and you
just have to sort of travel and you have
to figure out in what order should I
travel so this is a bunch of Mathematica
code that's figuring that out based on a
certain angle so now to apply it we
start with Nina's unbelievable
animations and so what I get basically
on the nerd side of the enterprise is
polygons and simplified for this bus yes
yes they're much the actual animations
as rendered for computer use our way
more detail than this but you know
thread its thread first thing I do as
you heard in last in Rogers talk i use
regions i think i started region using
regions in alpha versions of OS 10 or
Mathematica 10 slightly before they were
ready for prime time and there were many
bugs but it's gotten a lot better so
there I turn all the polygons into
regions and there's no hidden surface
removal so all of these things are sort
of stacked up you can see like the
shapes are complete then i use region
intersection i think is the function
call basically using the region
operations to punch out the things that
are underneath and then modify their
shapes a little bit because the thread
stretches so you want to you want to
make some adjustments to them it's all
you know it's a hundred percent region
code that's doing the geometrical
manipulation of these things and then I
apply that algorithm that you just saw
using a stitching Direction that's based
on the shape of the polygon to figure
out a pattern next question is in what
order should the colors be stitched so
for example if you were to stitch the
body first and then the hooves the
hooves would be disconnected from each
other so first you want you want to
stitch the hooves first because that way
you can travel through the body to get
to all of them without cutting the
thread and so there's a level of
analysis that's done with actually
surprising it's like two lines of
Mathematica that figures out what's the
optimal color order to minimize the
number of times that connected areas
become disconnected by having you know
been stitched first so in this for this
particular thing this is the order in
which it decides to fill in the colors
this is the time lapse of it actually
takes about five minutes
it's a bad time lapse but there you go
and at the very end you'll see wife
cutting the thread is bad yeah see
because when it screws up it's always
when it tried to cut a thread can do it
but you don't want to so this is a
collection of figures like that which
have been stitched together six on a
frame we did 516 of them each with a
unique design so in other words the met
the code all the geometry all the region
code all the stitches whatever is rerun
516 times on 516 completely different
designs as far as the stitching is
concerned and the result if we need
sound is somebody going to get a sound
you'll be head sound right okay so
here's the result it starts up not
actually a me by the way no one's ever
done this before in this kind of level
of detail and quality of embroidery
yeah this is like a test this is not
real yet get a look a lot better when
it's real it's a folks
there you go
yeah so so that was really an inordinate
amount of work to produce that I have to
say both you know both Mina's animating
and the mathematical processing and the
physical stitching of it like this
there's nothing photoshopped here those
are actual photographs of actual things
which are stacked up in the office now
raw like that's actually there which is
very satisfying but also very
labor-intensive and you know
fundamentally possible only because of
the sort of application of fairly
sophisticated mathematical techniques
made possible by these beautiful
algorithms built into mathematica and
and and and beautiful front end it lets
me play with these things and you know
experiment with these algorithms in a
graphically rich environment where i can
actually see these images right there in
the notebook and manipulate them as data
really satisfying to see how well
Mathematica actually works when you're
forced to use it to do something useful
well useful define in a certain way I
guess ok now it's Nina's turn ok so I
want to talk about single line art what
Te'o and I have been working on what
he's shown you so far is all draw things
Te'o will route them and process them
and Stitch code them so they can be
stitched but really computing could be
used more in the art side of it single
line art being the holy grail of
quilting design you don't want to break
thread so I actually made this holy
grail to try to illustrate this purpose
unfortunately I had to do this by hand
because I don't have any tools for
automatically taking my line art and
making it in a single line art the what
Te'o has been doing is amazing and it
involves back stitching this particular
one doesn't really have back stitching
this one just has a little line segments
taken out a little line segments added
to make it a single one piece of art but
anyway single line art TSP are traveling
salesman problem art anybody not
familiar with that that's sort of the
way single line art has been cracked
and the way that works is you have an
image you turn it into a set of staples
Moore's tipples where it's darker fewer
Sybil's where it's lighter you run a
path through it you continue running
that path you optimize it and eventually
it will look more like this I did some
tests using this actual process we have
not actually stitched this little piece
of embroider Mason this is very early
test and you can see that the fill
pattern is all one density and then
where it's not stitched is another
density I did this variation on it this
is supposed to be gray fabric with the
you know the object in dark thread and
the background and light thread but
different densities isn't the only way
you can achieve contrast and show images
with single line arta this is not
actually single line art because again I
don't have a tool for making this int
int if somebody wants to work on
developing tools allow me to make this
but can you know I'm looking at this
from an angle yeah I can see like
serious contrast from this angle these
lines are the same density I have to
phils of exactly the same density and
exactly the same pattern but they're
turned at right angles and because of
that you can actually see a shape here
it is closer and is it look like where
you get even more richness when you
start to vary the pattern so here I have
horizontal lines against a swirly
pattern close up again now when you have
these different patterns and then you
also start working with different
densities of line then you can get this
incredibly rich palette which is sort of
analogous to colors but it's all just on
the blinds again this is not a single
line but it could be a single line if
tools existed so back to travelling
salesman problem art it always has the
same look if you see a piece of TSP art
the the pattern that it's going to
generate is always going to look
something like this and this is familiar
to quilters who call this stippling this
was stitched by a quilter namely a day
who she is sort of like an online
teacher of free motion quilting or the
reason I got into it and here's another
fill pattern so stippling is just one of
thousands this one's called basic spiral
and you know it's an algorithm
and when you quilt these things by hand
you're like running a human-readable
algorithm which sort of puts you in this
meditative zou and I think that's why
people enjoy quilting and here is Leah
just describing the rules to a human
being they're very sort of vague they're
not very strict but there are rules I'll
just let her talk about them nice medium
sized spiral and you want to leave
enough space for you to kind of
backtrack and get back out of it and
then we're just going to kind of stack
two of these on top of one another and
you saw me kind of stitch that little
point right there what I was doing is
I'm just trying to fill in the space as
evenly as possible and occasionally you
have to make points like that and I
don't want these to start stacking up to
evenly so now i'm going to branch out
kind of make it a little bit more random
and start filling in some different
sizes and shapes of spirals sometimes
you're going to catch yourself you can
have some awkward areas like that area
right there where you're going to have
to make up the smaller shape or kind of
split it in half and so then you just
continue to fill in your area with
spirals and anytime you have a space
such as right here where there's not
enough space to actually stitch a spiral
but you still need to fill in that area
just stitch a point and that will fill
it in very nicely and kind of keep it
flowing very evenly but here's what it
looks like when you finish so there are
you know sort of an infinite variety of
variations on these designs Leah day has
cataloged more than 400 of them she
gives the ball names she makes a video
for every single one she has books of
them I have a couple of them here
there's way more that are possible as
far as I know people are not doing
things like this digitally and I would
like it if they did because currently
when I think of an art project that
involves fills like this I have to draw
it myself here's an example of one that
I did by hand and it's simple contrast
there's either a quilted or unquoted
area in the quilted areas I just
you know put all these different fill
designs in by hand they kind of they
almost start creating themselves after a
while if you do it for long enough and
that gives it like a richness even
though tonally it's just in contrast
with the unwanted areas but there's
there's no way I'm aware of that this
can be I mean that this has been
automated of course it can be automated
it hasn't been automated so for the work
that Te'o and I do I still have to draw
the fill patterns myself and the way I
do that is i'll draw some sort of
branching shape and maybe i'll add some
more branches as long as i don't make a
hole it works i'll convert strokes into
shapes I'll struck the whole thing get
rid of the shape and there I have like a
single line a space-filling curve this
one unfortunately i had to do by hand
even though it looks like a computer had
made it would be nice you know again if
the computer could make it there it is
stitched that's how I did the fill
pattern I was really hoping that you
know this could have been
algorithmically generated but we don't
have that yet but I'm hoping we will so
I drew this one by hand and that's
what's on our thousand-dollar bill a
similar technique for this you know this
this is more you know the human touch
but the the areas what you can only see
the areas in the corners those could
continue to be generated if you know
there were rules for it there it is
stitched front and back here's just
another example of it again all these
things I had to do by hand but it
doesn't seem like it needs to be so here
for this talk I just drew something you
know just drew like a single line fill
and then did a little computer time
lapse II thing I actually bought
software that would record what I was
doing and speed it up and this is not
knowing where I was going but I am
following certain rules as I'm drawing
it and if this were quilting it would be
you know a nice Phil and I really do
believe that a program could generate
something like this it's just it's not
yet that one's just running slow or I'll
skip that anyway here is that holy grail
again this is the drawing that I made
before I turn it in a single line art
right
laser pointer I could show you how it's
not actually a single line there's
there's little pieces of it that are
disconnected from other pieces so
another great tool would be something
that could take something like this and
just you know automatically find little
gaps that it could add a little line to
to jump across make the single line and
the other lines that were redundant if
they were small get rid of those but
instead I had to do that by hand and I'm
just you know showing you all this yes
basically listing all the things I
haven't managed to know no you for her
no you're not going to do them when when
this started tail was like Chris Carlson
Chris Carlson want to do it and chris
has actually worked on this a little bit
but there is so much that could be done
with this and I think it would be so
interesting because actually you know
what I think what you said was oh that's
been done i mean that's trivial right
like everybody you know yeah i assume
that somebody must have done this before
yeah hell not really not just the kinds
of patterns that she wants yeah also not
you know the single line the traveling
Chinese postman problem you know that
assumes that you actually have the lines
touching each other and that you are not
going to modify the grass you know in
her ideal algorithm the thing would
actually you know be equivalent of a
postman who says you know what that
street is just not important we're just
going to skip that one or you know if
there was a better road here just a
short little section of road if somebody
would build that everything would be
much easier and so let's make that road
and you know that's not within the scope
of what that those algorithms are able
to do and you know it's beyond my
mathematical depth to invent new
algorithms that would actually you know
have those sort of levels of
optimization built in yeah but i think
the space-filling curves is even more
interesting like and that's that sort of
generative you know organic algorithm
type stuff that i don't do yeah anyway
that's just I just wanted to show what
this problem is because this would be
amazing if it were cracked we could
really up our level of stitch art and
that's it
yeah she's okay so yeah so oh the quilt
plotter there's actually yeah there's
there's a guy the one person that sells
those in the United States they're made
in China just about any cheap quilt that
you get here we'll have been made on a
machine like that in China these have
been modified William Altman the company
is called quilt masters or quilting
masters or something like the machine is
it you know it's it's essentially an
off-the-shelf piece of industrial
production hardware for making quilts
it's just that normally there you know
much much simpler designs with maybe you
know two inches between rather than you
know a couple of millimeters between
lines here and they you know and they
all in China there's i think i think
when we bought this one it was the only
one west of the Mississippi or East the
Mississippi which side are we on when
he's the only one on our side of the
Mississippi that in this country because
there's just no reason to have a machine
like that here yeah and we're using it
stupidly using it insanely these are
incredibly inefficient to quilt because
these little swirly patterns on them go
so slowly they can do what 2,000 or
2,500 stitches a minute if it's a
straight line that's fast but this takes
so long the inertia of the head moving
that means it has to accelerate and
decelerate slowly and normally you look
at quilts you'll see that they're you
know they're these big sweeping arcs and
things that that are efficient for the
machine to do oh and if you're
interested in seeing this we can people
want to arrange a tour yeah we have our
course on the other side of town but
it's here yeah and also we're we have
meeting room number one downstairs if
you want to look at some of the
embroidery samples and other things like
we'll have a table of those so that
particular is that particular example is
filled with six density of stitches
everywhere you don't have to do actually
it brought somewhere in this piles of
stuff is some tests we were doing a kind
of used kind of very that in order to
help them produce more interesting
things of fill patterns and like I would
like to do for larger versions of the
goat I would like to do goat hair where
there's you know it's like scraggly
looking over stitching in such a way
that it looks kind of like a layered
haircut and I would also like to have it
respond to the movement so that like the
threads would kind of sway as the goat
is bouncing and I was also working on
some stonewall patterns using voronoi
diagram to generate what looked like you
know sort of stones that have been fit
together and then use contrasting
directions of stitches it's really it's
great having kind of the ability to just
if you can sort of mathematically
describe what you want then just
generated automatically rather than
having to draw these things by hand and
of course that's a prerequisite for
anything that we're doing because
everything has to be automatable because
it's going to get done hundreds and
hundreds or even thousands of times in
frames of animation and yeah if you come
downstairs we'll have ya have examples
to tell that yes right yeah well you
probably can't see them from here if you
have to touch them the stone walls in
particular i really like sort of texture
of them yeah and this is unlike any
existing embroidery software embroidery
software sucks it's really it's
criminally bad and expensive it depends
for the we fight over stabilizer guess I
Masterson I guess the embroidery all has
stabilized the quote stuff oh you didn't
show the tree the tree the yeah the tree
with the leaves falling we have an
embroidered flipbook that Te'o made it's
insane where is that yeah since we have
a little bit of time
here we go there's some other quilted
embroidery right this is this is our
first animated embroidery task of the
creek and this was this was during my
thick stabilizer phase what right so
this speaks to this is the flip book of
that
it's kind of hard to slip it exactly
because it sort of funny i was doing
this time the same time as i was writing
about disney we ended up sort of
recreating some of the early history of
hand-drawn animation because you know we
had that we actually made things and i
ended up making what's called a down
shooter which is how they made before
they invented the multi-plane camera
they they would have these these acetate
cells cellulite cells celluloid wherever
celluloid something you know they would
paint on and then they would stack them
up and you know lay them down flat on a
table with special pegs that were
patented special pegs and then have a
sheet of glass and there's a movie
camera up there and take some pictures
basically a guy who sits there for days
and days and weeks and months on end
putting a thing on put the glass down
push the button take a picture take it
all apart again put the next one down
put it down and I ended up doing exactly
that except I made an apparatus with
some you know folding halves and cutting
templates and things to to take sheets
like this that had been stitched cut
them precisely you see there's a kind of
a frame that it stitches around each one
that provides a reference that fits into
a frame gets cut out and then each fits
into another frame and held down and
there's a camera exactly the way they
made hand-drawn animation oh yeah and
then there's there's this one so this is
a thing which we have somewhere another
little test and here it is animated this
was an outtake from Sita Sings the Blues
a rotoscoped outtake and thao generated
the moving background pattern yeah I'm
mathematical waves what you notice
they're carefully adjusted so that they
cycle
yes and yeah and lots of stabilizer Nina
wants everything to be floppy and
irregular and I'm kind of trying to turn
this into an engineering discipline and
keep the fabric stable and not
stretching and you know it really bugs
me that like in the tree here you can
see there's have a little bounce to it
that drives me nuts the balance is not
supposed to be there that's failure
stabilizer well but this was its this
was one of our earliest projects and
this is where we realized that the next
project actually it turns out that the
systemic pulsing shake like that is
because of the stitch order being wrong
if it is stitched the frames in a
different order like doing one frame at
a time and rather than doing the you
know six on a sheet doing all the trunks
and then all the leaves of whatever it
wouldn't have shaken like that but it
was just it's too much work to do it
over again
okay so so vintage so the way this works
is you see again because of the desire
not to cut the thread the leaves are
stitched first and there's actually lots
of green thread underneath the branches
of the tree so they're all because
they're all connected to each other so
it never has to stop and then it goes
and does the branches of the tree and
covers that all up yeah I mean leaves
first in then the creek and it's done it
the machine can do sheets like that big
so it was doing six frames on one sheet
and I had to do all the leaves of one
color first and then all believes of
another color and then all the fruits
whatever and then all all the branches
and it should have done leaves of you
know on one frame and then the branch on
that frame and then moved on to the next
one because as it's adding more and more
thread everything is kind of pulling
together a little bit and shifting a
little bit yeah yeah I mean that it's
thread and it's annoying and it doesn't
go it's not like ink that stays put
from one leaf to another I think so the
algorithm first of all it's fairly easy
to do it's traveling salesman
optimization to find the leaf order and
I think I think that I had some sanity
checks in there where if it was going a
really insane distance you know up and
around these branches just it would then
stop and cut it because I mean the
machine can't do it it has a thread
cutter it's just that that's where the
failures occur and also it takes as long
to stop and cut as it does to stitch you
know several inches so it was you know
there's some there's some sort of you
know trade-offs there that I believe is
taking into account I forget that was a
while ago with quilting you can talk
about the shrinking issue and how are
you you know oh yeah what also be a
model driver I've been working on a
finite element model of fabric because
the the biggest problem of these things
is that as your stitching along that you
know the fabric is shrinking it's being
pulled together and so you know what the
problem is with the post mentor
optimization is you know signs a path
that's great but it doesn't consider the
fact that if you let's say stitch a
whole bunch here and then go off and you
know stitch a whole bunch over here and
then come back and finish up a little
bit over here that's really bad because
things will have shifted and I would
gladly pay a penalty of you know
duplicates stitching or whatever to keep
the locality of reference as it were
tighter and keep it and in fact the fact
that it's postman tour means it actually
tries in the optimization to get back
where it started from which is precisely
what you don't want and I've been
haggling to try to get a version of
these algorithms that don't try to come
back I just like start here finish
wherever you want I don't care about the
last gun that's you know I would like
that and the algorithm it would help a
lot but I would also like a penalty that
is to do with the age disparity between
neighboring paths and like minimize the
time there's a very old path in a very
new path next to each other that you
know I don't know I have no idea how you
go about
adding that into some of these
algorithms yeah it's early next my
backup plan is there's a finite element
model of the fabric where I can model
the stitching and model the shrinkage so
that one can then you know back that
into the positions and compensate for it
so that you know it'll come together but
the mesh is unfortunately i don't know
system model or i don't know how to use
it and i'm just trying to do it just
with fine minimum or whatever and it's
not working maybe someday yeah you can
see on this if you examine it you can
see some little places where things
we're stitch very important you out of
the line here which is really irritating
and you know if this stuff was just made
out of metal mesh and didn't stretch or
something but yeah i don't think you can
because when you like it takes so basic
operation is take one frame take all the
pixels out of that frame at a fairly low
resolution so you have then just turn
that into a soup of pixels and sort them
and there's you know you've lost all the
information about where they were so
there's no way that you can put it back
so the solution that we have for that in
the app is actually if we had an ipad
could very quickly plug in the app
because it's it's a it's a thing you
might want to do put that in if you sort
of know the movie but aren't really sure
is that working
look at that it works okay so if we go
to the giant color map thing so what you
can do is you can just touch any of
these things and it gets a little bigger
it gives you a thumbnail so you can
swipe through it and you can see the
thumbnail so like if you find Lion King
it's an and irregular ranking ok so
there's lion king and here you can see
like you know there's there's the happy
the blue and the greens are happy and if
you know the movie serve towards the end
it's just dark it's badass instant bad
and then it gets worse there's fire and
this is battling and everything is
really bad and and then that just gets
worse this night time in it's dark and
it's it's just miserable and raining and
then the morning dawns and it's
beautiful and blue and then we go to the
credits so that little stab of blue at
the end that's the happy ending and the
big bar at the end that's always that's
the end credits there and when you look
at the whole thing you can actually see
all kinds of things about the history of
Disney for example right here that's the
invention of end credits because you
notice before then the movie just kind
of ended and they listed a few people
like the most important people at the
beginning of the movie and they just
didn't list the hundreds of other people
that worked on it and then all of a
sudden they this phase transition they
realized like you can't list half the
people or a third of the people you can
either list the director and the
producer and six other people or else
you have to do everybody including the
baby born during the production which is
now standard on movies until the end
credits became incredibly long you can
also see when they made crap movies so
they spent a decade or two making really
bad movies which happens to correspond
exactly to the point where they became
dark so there's this kind of band in
here where the movies really not very
good
and I don't know I I prefer to think of
it as metaphorical or something you can
see the last couple have had incredibly
strong color palettes like wreck-it
Ralph is is just Stefan stop that record
Ralph is extremely you know reddish
pinkish sort of a thing and then frozen
is just astonishingly blue it's
basically all ice throughout the whole
movie it's really a question of what
what shade of light blue you want and
snow white smile towns this was our very
first movie and actually it's
interesting you ask about the color
transfer I don't think that's the case
because they're actually quite careful
about this and I asked the guy how how
do you know what the colors actually
looked like because nobody alive you
know they may remember they're people
who saw this when it first came out but
they were little kids then and now you
know they're in their 70s they don't
remember what those colors looked like
and the film has all you know faded and
how can you tell what did it really look
like and the answer is there's oil
paintings that were the backgrounds in
these movies and so they've gone back
and and those don't change you they were
stored in cold storage and dark and
archival vaults and it's quite you know
confidently you can say that the colors
have not changed and so they color
balance it to the oil paintings that
were the backgrounds of those movies so
this is actually the real colors of Snow
White pretty close maybe these other
movies the crap ones they didn't really
care about I don't know but but then you
know then they started making great
movies again and frozen was really good
in wreck-it ralph was really good and
you know there's some they've had
periods of making absolutely
astonishingly good movies and some
periods of not such great movies and
everything in between and what's really
astonishing is just the sheer quantity
of stuff that they have done over such a
long period of time so I think there are
I believe what we ended up was with a
thousand 24 frames per movie
so you know if the movie is a hundred
minutes long that would be ten frames so
like every six seconds roughly I think
that's what we ended up with so the
color maps plus the some nails I believe
was about 80 megabytes altogether the
thumbnails were all in one giant
compressed QuickTime movie so you know
it's the whole thing is all crammed
together into one thing which would then
picks the frames out of but you know
that's it's it's a challenge to oh this
is this is a to do with my new book
molecules and of course we made an
embroidered version of it embroidered
molecule oh no time it is are we
supposed to be stopping soon yeah I
think I think our time is up